foreign
[Music]
there is so much to see at Pac Expo
International come along for a quick
tour of all the must-see hot spots visit
the north building for the all-new
Logistics Pavilion to tackle your supply
chain challenges and find Next Level
learning and targeted Solutions at The
Innovation stage The Forum industry
speak sessions and other essential
destinations
in the south building you'll find the
package printing Pavilion featuring new
digital printing and converting labeling
coding and marking Technologies
visit The Confectionary Pavilion and
Candy Bar Lounge for Innovations and
conversations about candy and
Confections
next stop the Lakeside Center looking
for Best Practices to incorporate
reusables into your supply chain find
answers at the reusable packaging
Pavilion and learning center
the processing Innovation stage and the
processing Zone focus on advances in
food and beverage processing Solutions
and in the west building the excitement
continues the healthcare packaging
Pavilion is a packaging and processing
show within a show for anyone in the
Life Sciences Industries with more than
200 exhibitors showcasing targeted
Solutions and the containers and
materials Pavilion is an important
destination for anyone focused on
sustainability recyclability e-commerce
and consumer convenience
bookmark time to visit the Showcase of
packaging Innovations and see
award-winning packaging designs from
around the globe you'll also find pack
to the Future where you can follow the
evolution of modern packaging and
processing over the past 250 years
and explore key trends shaping the
future in live sessions occurring on the
PAC to the Future stage as a special
feature see the corrugated car of the
future VR experience from the paper and
packaging board
check out High School robotics teams
showcasing their design engineering and
troubleshooting skills at the future
innovators robotic showcase and the new
pack challenge where students will build
filling machines on site and of course
don't miss pack gives back a mega
networking event with a live performance
by Styx
[Applause]
[Music]
everything you need to see everyone you
need to meet register today